the popular idea i think in acting
sometimes is that you can't play two
things at once and then you can't play
irene because it's a lot of two things
at once
[Music]
pardon me i don't mean to stare but i
think i know you
claire
[Music]
i'm trying to find out the history of
the blondes you've brought along she's a
girl from chicago i used to know
princess from chicago
things aren't always what they seem
i'll be damned
lots of people pass all the time it's
easy for a negro to pass for white i'm
not sure it'd be so simple for a white
person to pass for color
so you haven't ever thought to what you
ever thought of passing no why should i
now i have everything i've ever wanted
this is my husband jambalu
does he no
do you dislike negroes mr bellew no no
not at all
i hate them
it's almost like we
made this thing and it doesn't exist
without an audience in a way that's what
felt so clear to me when we screened at
new york film festival which was really
my first time seeing the film
um
and so it feels you know like such an
honor for it to be in the world and for
people to be receiving it and i think i
feel similarly to rebecca in the sense
that
i think you make things
these babies of yours and you send them
off into the world and you hope they
don't get misunderstood and also you
hope that they can sort of be exactly
what they want to be in the world and
they'll find their home and so that's
sort of how i felt about
this film in a way is is
you know i don't mind things that are
polarizing i don't mind things that
confuse those who are the sorts of work
that always stay with me the most and so
i think i felt a little trepidatious
that maybe
no one would see us that we'd be sort of
the quiet shy kid in the corner that
people wouldn't want to play with or
engage with so it's a dream to know that
it's out on netflix and people can see
it really widely and i hope that you
know folks are having engaging
conversations around the world that's
always my hope i had been such a
longtime fan of rebecca's work as an
actor um had seen her own
pretty much everything she's ever done
um on film that i had seen her on stage
and i just thought she was so remarkable
and so i was first
interested to know that she was gonna
direct and
um and i thought of what a gift it would
be as an actor to get to work with
someone that clearly
um just understood performance and
sculpting characters and in such a
brilliant way
and then i was sent the
screenplay and i read the novella first
which i had not read before and wasn't
aware of and that was the first thing
that sort of alarmed me it felt like how
could i have not known that this book
existed
how is this not something that i had
been handed if not by a teacher by a
friend
um and so that struck me
and then i i read
the novella in one sitting
and then i immediately read rebecca's
screenplay and i couldn't believe uh the
way that she was able to articulate
the text in cinematic language in a way
that both satisfied this feeling of
ambiguity this feeling of being haunted
that you have when you read the novella
and also felt like
it took it into a new space a new
cinematic space um so i was so struck by
it and i knew that ruth nego would play
claire and
i so i had the great pleasure of reading
the novella thinking of
ruth um
and if you've read the novella you know
that it's such a sort of sensual
experience that irene has with claire in
some ways um and so it felt that way
reading the book imagining
you know ruth and her presence inside of
inside of the part and so i felt really
beguiled by the world and it was an
instant yes for me in fact i dropped out
of a project i was supposed to make
and then it took us a couple years to
get it made and i continued just to make
sure that
in so far as was possible with
contractual obligations that i would be
ready to make the film whenever they're
ready whenever the film was ready to be
made and so that's what i did i love the
idea of her as my savior um
um you know but i love i love that i i'm
not sure i mean
she unlocked so many plain irene
unlocked so many things inside of me
um
with regards to colorism and sort of
race i mean one thing that's interesting
is the conversation that
my character has with her husband ryan
played by the brilliant
andre holland
you know that conversation feels like it
could be plucked from a conversation
that black parents might have now
about um
you know how to best prepare your
children for the eventuality
um of racism inside of you know the
world and so that had a real modernity
to it that i think you know
uh was painful for both andre and i to
contend with and also
feels good it's this idea that i think
was so well articulated by nina simone
that if you're making art how can it not
reflect the time in which you're making
it and and i i certainly feel that way i
mean it's i feel like movies and pieces
of work regardless become
you know postcards of the time in a way
and so i love that inside of our film
which obviously is set
long ago there are ideas that feel
really relevant now one thing that i
think
irene has not unpacked is inside of that
conversation around what to tell their
children is she even has a measure of
privilege um by being lighter than her
husband by being a woman
um she doesn't have to go into the world
in the same way that her that you know
her black sons and her black husband do
and i think certainly one thing for me
has been unpacking my own layers of
privilege particularly inside of this
industry
um and and what to do with that frankly
you know i think we all have this idea
that um you know we we would be on the
right side of history when we look at
pieces that feel antiquated and i think
what doing a period piece allows you to
do
is to really interrogate how you would
show up um how you would have shown up
and i think it shows you a lot about how
you are showing up and so i think inside
of you know
the industry
yes there is a huge problem with
colorism one that i've participated in
when i was like an actor you know just
trying to get jobs in the beginning and
didn't have
frankly the privilege to think about the
implications of the parts that i was
playing because i was trying to make a
living um
but now i think is someone that's worked
in the industry for a while it's like i
don't really have that excuse anymore i
have i have a responsibility to
interrogate that inside of the industry
and and hopefully to try you know that's
one thing that feels really inspiring to
me in terms of producing is trying to
frankly create opportunities for black
women that don't look like me
um that haven't been afforded the the
privilege of hollywood's unfortunate
bias so i think for me the way
that irene
playing that part and certainly being
involved in a project were so generated
by women of color in part financed by
women of color i think it feels it's
activated me to go well just more of
that that's what we do we just make we
just do more of this
um and more often
i learned so much i've never worked with
a director first time or otherwise
um
that was
as
prepared as rebecca
um which i know i remember
nina our producer saying that she came
with the whole film storyboarded when
they met um just that had such clarity
of vision you know and that that's the
thing that
i think a director has to do in spades
is be able to
communicate not just
what the idea is to a whole host of
people but to be able to
like
translate
some of that passion so that everyone
around is like this is the absolute way
to do it and i've never i've never
really witnessed someone be able to do
that with such ease as rebecca
astounding to me that um
she hadn't done this before but in some
ways you realize she has because you
watch her performances and they seem
impenetrable by a bad director or a bad
decision by somebody else you know as an
actor you deliver a lump of clay and
someone else sculpts it and um
there's something about rebecca's
performances that you feel like she's
she has sculpted it inside of the
performance and that is that
requires such gifts so i think just
being able to
really engage with someone that was so
precise and yet so open
that was so
uh self-assured and sure of vision and
yet so flexible
um about the bits that that were that
that were able to have movement and
poetry and and that just made me feel so
safe and and held and i think
particularly in playing a character as
challenging as irene someone that has to
both
show and not show
um someone that you know i've
the popular idea i think in acting
sometimes is that you can't play two
things at once and then you can't play
irene because it's a lot of two things
at once um so just being able to work
with rebecca who is so so um
yeah so helpful in being able to chart
that and and also so
fantastic at making us all feel so safe
and held which i think is the space that
you can do kind of the scary
bits that are embarrassing to talk about
for me when irene is talking to her
friend hugh at this
ball um
a because i think there's sort of
one of the
a thesis in a way this idea that we're
all of us passing for something or other
i think it's like a nice indication to
the audience that if you have boxed the
film too squarely into a film that's
only about race um then you are missing
um the point a bit so i love that and
also it was one of my favorite days on
set because
just to see all of these beautiful black
folks moving in space dancing and
laughing and joyful um
it just
felt really rarified and made me think
about all the stories that might have
been told um
during the time you know if
if hollywood was interested in in
putting a lens on us and i think that's
like slightly connected there's a
beautiful question in the q a that this
person is asking is this is a story
that's very unique angled the lives of
of people of color in general black
lives specifically
that is usually not discussed are there
any aspects of daily lives of poc and
black stories that you're looking
forward to focusing on in the future and
i i like that because i think
to be able to capture
our daily lives in ways that are
undecorated and unadorned and i think
that what i love about passing is
there's real simplicity in a way
um and i don't think we often get as poc
and black bodies to exist in stories
like that and so i would just like to
see more of more of that and celebrating
and being able to look inside of like
our daily lives into our emotional
landscape i think that's the thing that
feels really exciting to me
you